jojo was geht hier ist euer max und
herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
heute spielen wir mal wieder was dabei
ist jetzt kein klassisches spiel ist wir
machen heute dass der hanauer game dabei
geht es darum dass man entscheiden
welche von zwei sachen öfter gesucht
wurde bei google und das klingt jetzt
mega blöd aber das ist richtig lustig
weil man denkt manchmal einfach nicht
wie oft beziehungsweise die selten
manche sachen gesucht werden und deshalb
dachte ich mir mache ich das heute mal
ich habe es selbst auf youtube gesehen
und los geht's so hier ist jetzt frage
nummer eins hat saturn also der planet
oder gillette mehr suchen voll krass
dass der planet saturn 335 millionen mal
gesucht würde wahrscheinlich auch so
einfach das wort saturn welche noch der
elektronik an und so was dabei aber
gillette rasierer ich sagt ehlert
weniger suchen als saturn richtig also
vielleicht nur 165000 prinz ist rihanna
hat mehr oder weniger als skelett 165000
ist nicht so viel bei dem spiel
aber da ist ja schon ziemlich bekannt
aber ich glaube so oft gesucht wird sie
nicht da ist noch mal eins cat diese
animation sind auch immer vollkommen
krachen quit playing baseball leitner
hat sie schämen sich für mich er mittels
leid aber leute das mache ich so denkt
man sich nicht david fincher keine
albers ist terrorism leute suchen ja
nicht terrorismus gläubig oder 135000
cristiano ronaldo hat mehr okay leute
wir sind schon bei scor zwei wir haben
es weiter geschafft hat eben trends die
serie hat weniger als cristiano ronaldo
xbox one mehr oder weniger als die serie
friends weiß es wirklich nicht
es ist richtig richtig schwierig xbox
one hat heino research conference
ich sage höhere und 14 millionen warum
suchen so viele leute xbox begleitet
weniger als vier millionen definitiv
leute fünf score haben wir schon
jennifer lopez höhere höher bei 3,35
millionen krass
anorexia also magersucht hat geringere
therapie aber 550.000 suchanfragen für
magersucht sind auch schon wirklich viel
man sich mal überlegt terrorismus hat
150.000 finde ich vollkommen
überraschend ich finde das ist mit das
lustigste beim spiel so weit muss das so
einschätzen aber du kannst es gar nicht
wirklich als hätte sagt ein rockstar hat
zu 100.000 50.000 oder so voll krass
therapie mit sagen mehr 90500 was ist
das denn apple store ist 32 also im
durchschnitt machen die leute 32 sachen
richtig es kommt jetzt auch bei mir
etwas hat jetzt 1 und 7 1 x also meinen
editions score ist sozusagen vier werden
nicht aufgeben bevor wir über zehn
kommen call of duty 2 4 millionen
christmas hat mehr 0 einfach pokémon
redet hat weniger sage ich ja was redet
hat elf millionen searches pokemon hat
fünf hatten wir gerade eben hat auch
fünf millionen also ich glaube es egal
für ja genau wenn es gleich das kriegt
man immer punktgleich fisch hat weniger
garantiert aber auch viele 135000 hat
mega viele das ist immer so bei den
ganzen superstars weißt du direkt ok
voll viel truman show kenne ich nicht
mal okay es auch bei wenig world work to
mehr mehr garantiert mehr 450.000 okay
bei 5 sind wir wieder racism passt gut
zusammen
rassismus oder zweiter weltkrieg was
wird öfter gesicht verpasst ismus oha
leute wir geben nicht auf
10 ist das ziel wir legen los wes
anderson 3 lassen sich tausendmal
schöner china hat mehr würdig sein islam
mehr als 15 seine religion verdammte
soll mehr hat face form oder hitler ich
sage facebook hatten mehr suchanfragen
eine million menschen suchen monatlichen
hitler alte schwede sind fernsehrat mehr
garantiert bmw hat mehr über sechs
millionen mal
santorini hat weniger aber auch viel
krass wie oft so und abseitige bradley
cooper hat er trotzdem sagen mehr auch
wenn er nicht krass nicht gedacht dass
der so oft besucht wird gold gate bridge
hat weniger es wird aber auch viel
besucht will ich sein
300.000 ist schon relativ wie black star
mehr gewesen bei sechs leute how to make
money weniger 301 1004 hat mehr wie
wenig aber nur jet li hat mehr dessen
leute [ __ ] holocaust ist richtig
schwierig wie oft wird der holocaust
gesucht also hitler wird eine million
mal gesucht der holocaust krass leute
wir sind bei neuen das ist jetzt die
entscheidende frage
ich würde fast sagen das wird seltener
gesucht also ich drück jetzt einfach
450.000 wieder so kurz davor ein 34
acht okay leute sind wieder ernst 9
ok ok damit dass damit sind die zehn
garantiert ja wir haben zehn geschafft
leute wir haben wirklich geschafft
10 x 10 10 richtig geraten unglaublich
hätte nicht gedacht dass das
funktioniert aber jetzt können wir
weitermachen ok und dass die nummer 11b
barrier reef wird nicht so oft gesucht
elf nicht schlecht x-factor results wird
bestimmt öfter gesucht wobei da muss man
aufpassen wie salz hat den unterschied
gemacht 90 prozent verschlechtert ich
war bei neun als ich neun hatte auch
schon so das war's vom heutigen video
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen schreibt
mir noch gern mal die kommentare was
euch so von meinen letzten videos am
besten gefallen habe ich habe ja ganz
unterschiedliche dinge gemacht und dann
orientiere ich mich daran so ein
bisschen
und ja das war es von heute macht es gut
und bis zum nächsten mal tschüss